التاريخ في صنع الآن
Sam Adventure Baker البالغ من العمر ثماني سنوات
وهو اسمه الحقيقي على وشك أن يأتي
أصغر شخص يصل إلى قمة
El Capitan في حديقة Yosemite الوطنية في كاليفورنيا
وهو موجود هناك مع والده
Joe Sam's Journey فوق الجرانيت
بدأ وجههم يوم الثلاثاء ، لقد كانوا ينظرون
إلى هذا الوجه الذي أمضوا
الليل معلقًا على جانب
التكوين الصخري الشهير في Park وهم
يشقون طريقهم إلى الأعلى ، وينضم سام بيكر ووالده
جو إلي الآن على الهاتف من أجل
تحدث عن كل هذا لأنك تعلم أنه في
بعض الأحيان ، حتى عندما نحاول استخدام
التكنولوجيا عندما تكون في مواجهة El
Capitan ، من الصعب تشغيل الفيديو ،
لذا كان Joe و Sam يتعاملان
مع اللكمات التقنية هذا الصباح من
الرائع  هل أنت سام أنك تقترب كثيرًا
من والدك أخبرني أنك
تمر بأصعب جزء ، كيف تشعر
بشعور جيد
، نعم وقليل من الإرهاق ،
لقد استيقظت للتو ،
أود أن أقول أنه من المفهوم أنك
مرهق قليلاً لقد كنت  لقد صُدمت
لأنك قرأت هذا ، لذا فأنت في الثامنة من عمر لديك
اسم رائع لأن اسمك الأوسط هو
Adventure ، لقد كنت تتدرب لمدة
عام ونصف ،
حسنًا
، وهكذا عندما بدأت في التسلق
بعد كل هذا التدريب ،
كان هذا يلبي توقعاتك ، لذلك  بعيدًا
سام ،
نعم ،
كنت أقرأ أنك قلت
إنك متحمس بشأن التسلق ، لكن
أحد الأشياء التي كنت متحمسًا لها أكثر
هو التسلق مع والدك
، لذا قل أن ذلك كان وقتًا جيدًا
ولكن سام كنت أتوقع منه أن يبكي  عدة
مرات في هذه الرحلة لأنها صعبة
وعاطفية لكنه كان صعبًا للغاية
وعمل من خلال كل ذلك ، لذا ،
بالمناسبة ، كنت خائفًا
هناك على الإطلاق
، أعني أنني أشعر بالخوف عند النظر إلى
بعض صورك  إنه أمر لا يصدق ولا
أستطيع أن أتخيل كيف يبدو الأمر عند
الاستيقاظ ، فهذه أنت ترسم هذه
الصورة الجميلة للشمس التي توقظك
، ولديك نظام التشغيل Vista الرائع هذا ، ولكن
حتى بعض مقاطع الفيديو الخاصة بك
تشير الكاميرا إلى الأسفل وعلي أن أفعل ذلك  تغطية عيني  إس